A Team is probably best modeled as a Kind.
It's a concrete structure that can have many entities.
A Game is also best modeled as a Kind,
for the same reasons as for Team. The Winning
Team is probably best modeled as an Entity. But,
this answer is not so straightforward. It could, for
example, be a Property Value in an Entity. A
Player is probably best modeled as a Kind for
the same reasons as Team and Game. And, the Player Name sounds
like it's modeled through a Property Value. I hope you did well on
the quiz. All right, that's an introduction to DataStore. Now, it's about time
to check out some code, don't you think? Let's do that. Good luck.